what was it like to work with paulie
shore honestly
and any thoughts were teaming up to
making an encino man 2 the older years
we have all indicated that we would be
more than happy to do a sequel
um personally i want to know what betty
nuggs looks like
30 years later so that was one of the
that was a cave girl that came up at the
end of the movie
i remember what about paulie paulie was
really focused
uh really knew his audience he was
really kind of
had a sweet spot in his life in his
career um
where he
he he was he was ambitious he was kind
of like
the opposite of his character so wait so
he didn't talk to you
in off camera like hey shaunie
what's up bob what are you doing today
no he was just very protective
of the fact that he had his hit mtv show
and this thing was going on and he
didn't want
he was just protective of it so no he
would talk to me but we didn't get on
that great
um because i didn't really want to be
doing the movie wait you didn't get
along that great
well i mean whatever we got i mean it
wasn't like there wasn't any bad
anything but he
knew he didn't want to do it so there
was a little bit like uh he didn't even
want to be here
no i was kind of like i had done some
movies
that were substantial movies right like
what besides the goonies and
rudy and uh i did memphis spell
substantial in right like
history on the historical spell is a big
name but memphis bell was a movie that i
did that was i think kind of an
important movie it was uh
kind of a love letter to veterans of the
the air war in europe and
um it was david putnam you know who did
chariots of fire and
and the mission it was a very memorable
movie but he
but you didn't it took a lot to get you
to do this scheduling and you weren't as
passionate
so there probably was a little bit of
animosity or whatever i get it
right not animosity just be like
throwing that word at you
i just threw it out like you're like
yeah
on different pages but like like brendan
fraser and i would play video games in
the
dressing room awesome we'd be like and
cut and we'd run to the dressing room
and go in the dressing room and play a
video game
you know like we were we bonded like
that um
later in life and times paulie and i
i think like we i we like each other
like we're we're i think we'd be happy
to be
interacting together and i think i my i
appreciated
who he was and what he was doing at that
time but it just was not my scene
i'm just not the like guy's gonna like
play a bunch of college campuses and
you know talk about you know just be
hitting on all kinds of girls and
i don't know it just wasn't my it just
wasn't my vibe but i got why it was
why he had the audience i got why it was
fun and funny right for him
i just was it was me i was a problem